the left is not interested in unity or
healing they're lying and pretending
that they are so that we roll over and
prematurely concede a presidential
election but in their moments of honesty
they're telling us what they really want
to do and that is punish
conservatives aoc tweets out quote is
anyone
archiving these trump sycophants for
when they try to downplay or deny their
complicity
in the future i foresee decent
probability of many deleted tweets
writings photos in the future their
complicity
is anyone archiving those who have
supported trump why
why does she want to archive people's
support for trump
is it so she can give us awards in the
future
so she can give us a pat on the back i
don't think so she's going to give us
something in the back probably not a pad
they want to punish people who have
supported trump
you you did not see this from the trump
administration when the trump
administration entered
you did not see them trying to punish
obama-era people
they the one the one group we do want to
punish are the deep staters who who
spied on the trump campaign and who
tried to overturn
the the duly elected president from 2016
to the present
which i think has a lot to do with this
particular election
but you didn't see us saying we're going
to punish obama supporters for giving us
obamacare
never happened but the left is
vindictive trump was not supposed to win
in 2016.
it wasn't supposed to happen it was a
glitch in the system the ruling dominant
liberal regime and they are out for
blood for anyone who allowed that glitch
to happen they sure weren't going to let
it happen again in 2020
and they're fighting tooth and nail to
prevent that
when we joke about we would say oh
they're going to send us the gulags
sometimes i wonder i say are we just
being you know
overly emotional here do they they don't
really want to send us to the gulags
they do
they do aoc has told us i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts